guests who just got murdered he's
leaving our plan worked we saved our own
honeymoon and fun bonus we cheered up
halt yes okay it's time to celebrate you
know what that means this bee needs a c
in her a oh my God this babe needs a
coconut in her arms oh Oh I thought you
were saying this music oh my God that
was my reaction all right I'll go get us
a couple of coconuts God I missed this
place let me just soak it in
oh yeah stale coffee fingerprinting ink
whatever Charles is fermenting in his
desk beans beans it's like I never left
all right fill me in tell me everything
I missed it won't take long only three
things happen Terry chipped his tooth
and had a lisp for a week listen up even
I'm sorry did I say something amusing
you answer me you son of a number
two Santiago and Boyle wore the same
outfit to work one day
[Music]
how does it look better on you and
Captain banned headphones from the
office due to the Gina incident
[Music]
so again your Alibi is a mysterious
stranger handed you the gun made you put
your prints on it robbed the store and
then hid the gun in your underpants Well
yeah if you say it like that it don't
sound believable oh hey Captain did you
get my report on the Findlay murder oh
yeah looked it over nice work good
thanks Dad
why is everyone staring at me you just
called Captain hold dad he said thanks
Dad what no I didn't I said thanks man
do you see me as a father figure Peralta
no if anything I see you is a bother
figure because you're always bothering
me hey show your father some respect I
didn't call him Dad no no no no Jacob I
take it as a compliment it's not a big
deal I called Vivian mom once and she's
my fiance guys jump on that Boyle has
psychosexual issues old news but you
calling Hulk Daddy hey Daddy is not on
the table here but you did call him dead
dude you shut up you've done nothing but
lie since you got here all right all
right I was lying about the holdup but
the dad thing that happened
he admitted that his Alibi was a lie it
was a trap all part of my crazy devious
plan I believe you thank you son
you want to talk about it later over a
game of catch
I'd like that so do you recognize any of
these men I was hiding in the bathroom
stall so I didn't see his face but I
heard him he was singing along to the
music at the bar do you remember what he
was singing I think it was that song I
Want It That Way Backstreet Boys I'm
familiar okay
number one could you please sing the
opening to I Want It That Way really
okay
you are
My Fire
number two keep it going the one
desire number three believe when I say
number four I want it that away tell me
why ain't nothing but a heartache tell
me why you ain't nothing but a mistake
now number five I never wanna hear you
say
[Applause]
ah chills literal chills it was number
five number five killed my brother oh my
God I forgot about that part look I know
that dog meant a lot to you so I got you
this
it's a dog
his name's Arlo but you can call him
Jason too or whatever seriously I can't
just replace Jason with some other dog
why not all dogs are basically the same
watch this Arlo go hump that toy
away from that
look man I've been patient we have a
case we need to work on it's time for
you to get over it move on move on move
on
Jason was part of my family Rosa I loved
him his humping was the only thing that
got me through my divorce seeing him so
happy made me believe that I could be
happy one day too
you wouldn't understand this because you
have a motorcycle helmet for a heart but
I need to feel this sadness so the only
thing that I'm moving on from is you
so I like have a dog now
I've only had Arlo for a day and a half
but if anything happened to him I would
kill everyone in this room and then
myself very violent eulogy I like it for
you
and you and you what are these these
madam are STDs
what are you talking about Buddy STDs
save the dates for Viviana my wedding ah
yes hey just out of curiosity how many
people have you given STDs to Lots like
a hundred
what's going on uh oh okay I get it STD
has another meaning you're gross no one
else is going to think that everyone is
going to think that but it's sweet that
your mind didn't go there thank you it
is kind of sweet will your first dance
be too you give me fever will you be
serving crabs at the reception do you
have herpes guys this is my wedding this
is important to me no more jokes you're
right and we're sorry yes we love you
buddy warts and all it's all right I
made a rash decision I was itching to
say it okay I'm done
I have an STD
so just RSVP or yeah the number's right
on the instruments great come on Sir the
math thing isn't the problem night
shifts keeping you and Kevin apart you
two just need a bone
what did you say don't say it again I
said you two need a bone
oh
Dare You detective Diaz I am your
Superior officer phone what happens in
my bedroom detective is none of your
business
don't ever speak to me like that again
look Kevin is over yep because you
understand the map nope because you guys
yep you lost all control and you
bludgeoned him to death there must have
been blood everywhere but you got lucky
you were in the surgical Suite it can be
sterilized you never would have gotten
away with it in your carpeted office
that's not what happened don't say
anything more and your office manager
would have heard all of the screaming
but she was at her grandson's play lucky
again you're wrong you put Robert's body
into a wheelchair and shoved it in the
elevator it's a miracle there wasn't
blood everywhere that's not true now
you're in the garage with a corpse you
panicked and left your phone in your
office and you don't have your car keys
but Roberts are in his pocket so you put
him in his car and you take off you
can't believe what you've done no you're
flustered you have no GPS so you just
start driving no next thing you know
you're in the pine Barons and it hits
you your uncle's cabin he has a place
there you're the luckiest son yes it was
you got lucky at every turn no I knew
exactly where I was driving I left my
phone in the office on purpose I was in
a surgical Suite by Design and I didn't
use some glass award that any idiot
would clearly see was missing I made a
rod out of a special dental polymer
killed him with it then melted it back
down it's already in a patient's mouth
son
thank you
ladies and gentlemen I present Carl
Lawson who stole three thousand dollars
Santiago takes the lead with one minute
left suck at Peralta oh no that's right
oh no oh no you don't seem worried why
are you worried bring in the Giants
I ran a prostitution sting through Vice
and arrested 30 guys for soliciting
that's not a felony it is when it's your
second offense which is the case for 10
of these gentlemen fun fact four of them
are actually named John ironic anywho 10
more for Peralta accept your fate never
five four three two one Jake wins Amy
loses
[Music]
[Applause]
look
at times
[Applause]
Amy Santiago
you have made me the happiest man on
Earth
I spent one whole dollar on this ring
will you go on the worst date ever with
me you have to say yes
yes she said yes
good boy cheddar bring me that Karma bun
wait a minute
this isn't the championship cummerbund
this is some common cumberbund
you're not cheddar these are some common
Terry said he has some news from
the office of commissioner one sure what
does that human blister one now does she
intend to demote me even further or
perhaps she'll transfer me to the swamps
of New Jersey so I can Patrol the
sinkhole where she was spawned or it's
possible the announcement has nothing to
do with you oh good thank you berota
you're right maybe Madeline wants to
inform us all that she's a juicing a
what a chooxon a Korean toilet ghost
lives in an outhouse wraps her hair
around your throat and chokes you to
death while you move your bowels you
know what I will give you six thousand
dollars if the announcement is she's at
jukison okay everyone I have some news
so Madeline once is a Korean toilet
ghost boring we already knew that
Madeline lunch is dead say what now my
emotions aren't overdrive well I know
just the thing to cheer you up lunch is
dead bagel bagel bagel sir I am loving
this color on you but don't you think
you should tone it down why in case I
run into a family I'm not planning any
trips to the Bronx Zoo